[Applaus]
[Musik]
hast du eigentlich gewusst dass der sie
auch von google sondern in indien
geboren wurde ebenso wieder überaus
erfolgreiches iv von microsoft satya
nadella
und jetzt ratet mal wo der seehofer und
adobe geboren wurde
die us anleihen wurde ebenfalls in
indien geworden
tja es sieht ganz so aus als würde
indien das ganze liegt überlegt
übernehmen ja eigentlich die software
industrie weltweit was meisten sie zum
beispiel die größten
dienstleistungsunternehmen der welt nein
accenture ist es nicht und dies ist
schon gar nicht es ist dies eine
indisches unternehmen so und jetzt
fragst du dich wahrscheinlich indien ist
das nicht auch ein entwicklungsland und
das ist in der tat war 73 millionen
leben in extremer armut 78 millionen den
slums nur circa acht prozent der inder
haben einen hochschulabschluss
verglichen mit 34 prozent der us-bürger
und jetzt hatte ich mal fest 25 prozent
der inder sind sogar analphabeten denn
in denen das sind eigentlich zwei länder
in einem das arme indien und tech india
und wenn dieses tech india ein
eigenständiges land wäre wäre es so
wohlhabend wie deutschland es hat ein
bruttoinlandsprodukt von 177 milliarden
us dollar das sind 24.000 dollar broker
es würde vier millionen arbeitnehmer
beschäftigen denn alleine die vier
großen indischen it-unternehmen tcs
infosys und wipro beschäftigen über eine
million hoch qualifizierte mitarbeiter
und falls du wie ich auch in der aktiven
arbeit ist hast du sicher schon mal mit
kindern zu tun gehabt denn fast jedes
größere unternehmen hat schon mal nach
indien outsourced denn indische software
entwickler werden weltweit geschätzt
viele von ihnen landen im silicon valley
und in spitzenpositionen wie eben
erwähnten sie aus aber trotzdem
hinterlässt das alles viele offene
fragen denn offensichtlich haben wir
einen großen widerspruch
auf der einen seite ist indien ein land
mit riesigen bildungsprobleme und auf
der anderen seite ist ist der
zweitgrößte software exporteur der welt
nun heute werden wir diesen widerspruch
für euch natürlich auflösen und das ist
uns wie immer ein blick zurück in die
geschichte
[Musik]
die richtige idee aber der falsche weg
viele leute ihren indien mit mahatma
gandhi aber gandhi wurde 1948 ermordet
bevor in denen seine erste verfassung
verabschiedet
denn tatsächlich ist die entscheidende
figur in unserer geschichte nicht mehr
hatten und dann diese mann
seines zeichens erster premierminister
indiens von 1947 bis 64 unter seiner
regierung wurde die erste verfassung
eines eigenständigen unabhängigen
indiens verabschiedet aber ernährung
hatte darüber hinaus noch eine ganz
andere vision er wollte die ehemalige
britische kronkolonie zu einem pionier
in der computer herstellung machen aber
wie um alles in der welt sollte indien
das damals schaffen ohne er und dachte
natürlich er hätte die lösung dafür
gefunden
anstatt sich am britischen modell zu
orientieren ließ sich nero von stalin
inspirieren so führt in die viele
kommunistische elemente ein wie zum
beispiel fünf jahres planung und ein
importverbot für güter um die lokale
industrie zu fördern
mit hilfe dieser fernseher schafft und
informationen entstanden nationale
gedanken die stark vom staat gefördert
wurde der wichtigste davon ist ein
mischkonzern tata der in europa vor
allem für billige autos bekannt ist aber
teil macht noch viel viel mehr
er gründete die erste fluggesellschaft
indiens und auch die erste indische
computers thema theater computer
services oder tcs parallel dazu
investierte die regierung stark in
bildung in den 160 jahren wurden viele
technische universitäten die sogenannten
wende ist technology oder it gegründet
in diesem sollten viele juden der darauf
vorbereitet werden in der aufstrebenden
computerindustrie zu arbeiten das
problem dabei es gab keine unternehmen
für die sie arbeiten konnten
denn abgesehen von katar gab es so gut
wie keine anderen technologieunternehmen
der grund ein unglaublich schlechtes
klima für gründe denn dadurch dass
technologie importe verbunden wurden gab
es ja keine komponenten auf
internationalen politics niveau auf die
diesel neuen kleinen firmen hätten
zurückgreifen können und so gab es in
den siebziger jahren in ganz indien nur
etwa 150 computer und diese wurden alle
von ibm importiert den ibm das irgendwie
gelungen die strengen vorschriften des
indischen marktes zu umgehen alles in
allem war das also für nero ein riesiger
bauchplatscher so jetzt kommt aber
unsere zweite protagonist in unserer
geschichte
dann die sieger in den sechziger und
siebzigerjahren indische premierminister
an indira gandhi ist übrigens wieder die
tochter von mahatma gandhi doch
irgendwie mit ihm verwandt sie ist
vielmehr die tochter des ersten
premierminister und siehe da die kugel
vorher kann
was die einzigen computer in indien von
einer ausländischen firma importiert
wurden dummerweise folgte sie habe
einfach nur weiter der logik ihres
vaters sie dachte einfach dass die
vorschriften nicht streng genug seien
und so verabschiedete sie 1973 den
foreign exchange regulation act welcher
die einfuhr von computern fast unmöglich
machte dies gab dem markt den letzten
schlag und sogar ibm zog sich noch im
selben jahr aus dem indischen markt
zurück tja und wenn du jetzt vielleicht
denkst das wären gute nachrichten für
die indischen hersteller geht diese
lücke dann irgendwie fühlen könnten tja
falsch gedacht das gegenteil war der
fall
denn damit verschwanden computer
praktisch völlig auseinander und indien
konnte auch keine computer exportieren
der beschränkungen führen fast immer zu
gegenreaktionen der anderen länder und
deswegen kaufte die welt lieber
amerikanische und japanische produkte
also wie schaffte in denen dann doch
noch die kurve nun das ganze spiel
änderte sich 1932
[Musik]
lehren aus den eigenen szene
1982 waren der gastgeber der asien
spiele
das ist so etwas wie die olympischen
spiele aber nur für asien und der
organisationschef dieser spiele war
niemand anderes als dann die diesmal er
war da so von indira gandhi ja scheinbar
ist die ganze indische politik so was
wie ein familienunternehmen aber dieser
gandhi war ganz anders als seine mutter
denn er verstand wirklich etwas von
technik und er wollte computer für die
asienspiele einsetzen aber als er dann
munter zur tat schreiten wollte merkte
er dass es im ganzen land eigentlich
fast keine computer gibt aber archiv gab
nicht auf für ihn war es eher so etwas
wie ein weckruf sein 1984 wurde seine
mutter von zwei leibwächtern ermordet
und relativ wurde wie es in einem
familienunternehmen wird also indien
braucht ist premierminister und schon
zusammen amtsantritt versucht er eine
180 grad wende der indischen industrie
politik erhob viele zölle und
importverbote auf utah kommunen
vollkommen zollfrei importiert werden
solange sie der entwicklung falls
verdienten
aber daran die so technisch versierte
war musste er das ist eigentlich zu spät
war um indien eine führende rolle in der
hektik zu sichern deswegen fasste er
schon die nächste revolution ins auge
software und er lag damit natürlich
goldrichtig
bist du es lateinamerikanischen
software-entwicklern sechsstellige
gehälter zahlen zu müssen dann bist du
goldrichtig bei tag im jahr
universitäten auf dem neuesten stand der
technik braucht qualifizierte und
hochgradig motivierte mitarbeiter und
was du meinst du was das alles kostet in
einer nahen ein indischer programmierer
kommt sich nicht nur 10 20 oder 30
prozent günstiger als ein amerikanischer
nein da kostet mich noch nicht mal die
hälfte
mein gott du wirst das was ich jetzt
sage nicht lassen können denn du
bekommst das alles top ausgebildete
experten die fließend englisch sprechen
ist alles lauter mathe asse
das alles sei ein unglaubliches fünftel
eines amerikanischen programmierers nur
20.000 deiner bisherigen lohnkosten und
mit den 80-prozentigen mit teck india
sparst du expandieren oder eine große
party schmeißen auch warst du kannst
expandiert jeden tag eine riesen party
schmeißen
denn das ist nur möglich bei tee und das
beste ist wenn muss noch nicht mal mit
einer lokalen firma zusammenarbeiten
oder ein büro in indien einrichten
denn wir haben keine kosten und mühen
gescheut uns für dich alles so bequem
wie möglich zu machen
wir haben sogar eine satelliten gebaut
damit das unternehmen dort
amerikanischen hauptsitz uns einfach
deine mission aussehen wie wir
kommunizieren kannst rechtzeitig tiere
also auch du von der teck in davos nur
sparen bares geld komplett anders gerade
getan
texas instruments hatte auch schon getan
sogar die em hat ein großes comeback auf
unserem markt erlebt denn jeder spart es
in der verpasst nicht diese riesen
gelegenheit so musste ihre kosten zu
sparen wie nie zuvor
ruf jetzt sofort an 0 800 tag in der
subventionen und steuererleichterungen
sich die rathenower englischen
steuerberater und plötzlich schoss die
zahl der computer von 1000 im jahr 1968
auf über 80.000 im jahr 1990 hoch
unternehmen die tata computer services
oder hindus dann computers wurden zur
russischen partner für große us firmen
wie hewlett packard und die regierung
war mehr als glücklich dennoch früher
als westliche nationen lassen der indien
pionierarbeit bei elektronischen
wahlautomaten computergestützten
bankgeschäften und sogar digitalen
bahnfahrkarten und die ganze welt
betrachtete indien als hauptanlaufpunkt
für ihr auslöste
die computer revolution kommt nach
indien auf ihre eigene weise
etwa zur gleichen zeit wurde die
national association of software service
kommt wenn ich nachts kommen begründet
sie wurde die führende lobbyorganisation
für die liberalisierung der indische
software industrie aber ging das
wirklich alles so einfach führte diese
marktliberalisierung ganz automatisch
dazu dass indien von internationalen
unternehmen überrannt wurde
nun nicht ganz denn es gab hier einen
kleinen trick das wirklich noch alle
indischen universitäten und an all die
absolventen die in indien keine arbeit
fanden weil keine kleinen
gründerunternehmen konnten nun viele
davon gingen ins silicon valley und die
einfluss in den us firmen stieg und
steht jedes jahr und dies hat der
rückkopplungseffekte zurück
und diese auslands in der halle in die
strategie rung eine gesetzgebung zu
schaffen die genau auf die bedürfnisse
der unternehmen zugeschnitten ist
außerdem überzeugten sie ihre energie in
die emsstadt für andere länder zu
entscheiden wenn es unnötig ausgegeben
ein gutes beispiel dafür wie viel
praxisorientierung dies brachte sind
dieses satelliten die indien baute um
die indische büros mit den
amerikanischen firmen zu verbinden was
war etwas woran niemand anderer als die
branche gedacht habe und durch all
dieser effekt wurde eine positive
rückkopplung ein selbstverständlicher
kreislauf für die indische it industrie
in gang gebracht ja selbst die
finanzkrise der neunziger jahre diente
dem interesse von ted india denn wer die
indische währung wie verrückt abwertete
und der rest der wirtschaft unter der
starken inflation liegt wurden die
exportorientierten software firmen noch
wettbewerbsfähiger und so kam es dass im
jahr 2000 die indische software
industrie bereits über 5 milliarden
dollar schwer war
tja aber selbst diesen riesigen blumen
sollte ein weiterer wendepunkt
vollkommen in den schatten stellen denn
mit dem jahr 2000 kam etwas was tech
india weltweit noch viel wichtiger
machte
das jahr 2000 problem
diejenigen die sich dieses video ansehen
und über 30 jahre alt sind erinnern sich
vielleicht an diese geschichte
hast du dich noch an die sogenannten
millennium butt viele experten warnten
damals vor dem ende der welt wie wir sie
kennen aber worum ging es dabei
eigentlich dass ein jahr 2000
computerfehler als eine weltweite krise
und als eines der schwerwiegendsten und
potenziell verheerenden ereignisse denen
dieses land je begegnet ist also
speicherplatz noch früher in den
sechziger und siebziger jahren teuer
daher benutzten die programmierer einen
kleinen kniff sie speicherten nur die
letzten beiden ziffern einer jahreszahl
zum beispiel 60 für 1960 oder 10 für
1910 so konnte bei jeder datumsangabe
etwas speicherplatz gespart werden ja
aber das dicke ende kam dann später wenn
viele dieser programme die mit
jahreszahlen großer 2000 hatte ich
umgehen konnten liefen viele jahrzehnte
lang bis in die 90er jahre und eben auch
über das jahr 2000 hinaus und dies kommt
in der tat zu schwerwiegenden fehlern
oder abstürzen führen und als das jahr
2009 verwandelten die medien dieses eher
technische problem natürlich wie so oft
in eine irrationale angst und panik die
apokalypse unter zusammenbruch der
zivilisation wurden vorhergesagt und
während einige medien noch bis zum
kritischen jahreswechsel 99 2000
besorgte berichte verbreitet hatten
stellte sich dann anfang 2000 heraus
dass die vorsorglichen massnahmen im
großen und ganzen ausreichend gewesen
waren
das ende der welt fand auch diesmal
nicht statt nichtsdestotrotz die mediale
hysterie sorgte für einen wahren
geldregen bei den softwarefirmen und die
indischen war ganz vorne mit dabei
denn woher sonst sollte die welt auf
einmal so viele zusätzliche
programmierer her bekommen und so
fühlten sich myriaden fleißiger inter
durch milliarden von teilen
die zeit in indien werden millennium bug
beißt zu
indien war damals einfach zur rechten
zeit mit den rechten leuten zur stelle
denn das was es zu bieten hatte war
weltweit einmalig jedes jahr 100.000
neue ingenieur absolventen das teilt der
indische programmierer lag nur bei einem
sechstel des niveaus und nasscom der
lobbyverband montag via schickte eine
armee von vertrieblern auf jede messe
der welt von luxemburg bis osloer von
new york bis zur see unser erfolg war
riesig 1998 machte der millennium bug 40
prozent der einnahmen von tec gmbh aus
der millennium bug heißt indien damit
sich als führender software macht zu
positionieren und im laufe des nächsten
jahrzehnts also den 2000er jahren
festigte in den diese position indem ist
das closing auch auf high end bereiche
ausweitete also forschung und
entwicklung alt die architektur &
process integration globale unternehmen
richteten in den offshore zentren für
strategieberatung und end to end
lösungen ein
darüber hinaus war das business process
outsourcing ein riesen rennen was das
ist das ist die auslagerung kompletter
generischer geschäftsbereiche alle
kundenkontakte oder die bearbeitung von
versicherungs ansprechen und so schoss
der indische it sektor im vergangenen
jahrzehnt über zwei millionen neuer
arbeitsplätze oder 10.000 neue
technologie unternehmen so und heute ist
der indische it industrie 177 milliarden
dollar schwer
ende gut alles gut möchte man meinen
aber moment mal
denn an dieser stelle endet unser
schönes märchen von teck india denn
jetzt zeigen dir die dunkle seite der
indischen macht
[Musik]
in den zwei länder in ein es gibt noch
eine weitere sache für die indien
berühmt und berüchtigt ist sein
kassensystem denn in dem ist eine
knallharte klassengesellschaft und das
ist alles andere als klasse und wenn du
mir sagt ist die neue moderne bunte und
schillernde welt wäre da ganz anders
antwort der leistungsorientierung der
gleichheit und emanzipation dann wirst
du dich gewaltig das genaue gegenteil
ist der fall
die indische industrie ist das beste
beispiel dafür wie in indien die schere
zwischen arm und reich immer weiter
aufgeht denn worum handelt es nicht
eigentlich bei dieser geschichte von
cathleen ja genau
nun es geht um eine kleine insel des
wohlstands die von einem mehr des elends
umgeben ist ein reiches indien inmitten
eines armen indiens sicherlich ist es
großartig im indien im it bereich zu
arbeiten als entwickler kann mit einem
gehalt von etwa 10.000 us dollar pro
jahr loslegen und karriere machen
okay das klingt für westliche
verhältnisse nicht noch einen besonders
hohen einkommen aber in indien kann man
davon sehr gut leben denn in einer stadt
die bänke law kostet eine wohnung zum
beispiel weniger als 200 dollar im monat
aber der zugang zu tecan die ja
erfordert ein hohes bildungsniveau gute
englischkenntnisse und eine menge
soziales kapital und das sind dinge
welche für die meisten in der immer
unerreichbar sein werden ein
programmierer zu sein ist der ultimative
indische traum
es gibt nicht nur darum in städten wie
angela oder mumbai einen guten job zu
bekommen es geht auch um die aussicht
arbeit im ausland zu können
japan ist auf der suche nach indischen
täglich aber werden diese anbeißen sie
die das deutsche visums angebot lockt
indiens it experten nicht an
gerade im silicon valley sind 50 prozent
der gastarbeiter mit den berühmten
export wie visum inder
ähnlich sieht es auch in seattle aus wo
amazon und microsoft ihren hauptsitz
haben aber jetzt halt dich mal fest der
lange arm des indischen kastensystems
reicht um die ganze welt ja es herrscht
sogar selbst in den zentren der vogue
kultur
du findest das unglaublich nur die
menschenrechts organisation equality lex
hat im rahmen ausgiebiger studien
herausgefunden dass in der aus den
untersten kasten in es unternehmen und
universitäten also unternehmen wie
facebook amazon oder microsoft
systematisch diskriminiert werden und
ausgerechnet die tatsache dass es in der
it-branche der usa schon so viele in der
gibt wird der mitglieder der unteren
kasten zum fluch und du kannst mir
glauben dass dies für die betroffenen
kein zuckerschlecken ist wenn hinter den
abstrakten begriff der diskriminierung
stecken verbale und körperliche angriffe
erniedrigungen benachteiligung im
bildungssystem und bei beförderungen und
sogar sozialer exklusion diese geht
sogar bis zur wahl des sexual und
lebenspartners das heißt in der aus den
höheren kasten lehnen es ab die aus den
niedrigeren zu denken die meisten
angehörigen der unteren kasten versuchen
daher ihre herkunft unter allen
umständen einzuhalten und leben auch in
ihrer neuen heimat in ständiger angst
vor einem outing dennoch ist es der
traum der meisten in der einen dieser
jobs zu bekommen und in diesem ticket
aus dem mehrheits in die nacht india
fliehen zu können
mein ticket nach draußen das indische
dorf in dem jede familie ein ingenieur
hat der guardian im dorf bartoli in
nordindien beispielsweise hat sich die
ganze gemeinde zusammengeschlossen
sie stellt ressourcen und einrichtungen
bereitet damit kinder an einer der
indischen universitäten studieren können
die eltern legen alle ihre ersparnisse
zusammen und nehmen darin auch nur und
damit die nachhilfe unterricht ihrer
kinder bezahlen zu können damit diese
später die aufnahmeprüfungen der
begehrten studienfächer bestehen können
im jahr 2017 wollen sollen sich
studenten aus diesen einem dorf an der
technischen universität aufgenommen aber
trotz all dieser anstrengungen machten
die unteren kasten nur neun prozent des
gesamten lehrpersonals an den
hochschulen aus was geschieht also in
westindien warum wächst ist nicht so
stark wie tekken er nun die wahrheit ist
dass indien abgesehen von computern
immer noch ein zutiefst
protektionistisch das land ist und ein
wahres paradies der bürokratie gemäss
dem ease of doing business index also
dem ranking der länder nach ihrer
geschäfts freundlichkeit rangiert indien
irgendwo neben saudi arabien oder der
ukraine wird es nur ein beispiel so jede
indischen zustände haben die selbst
kafka im traum nicht eingefallen wären
tja da könnte ich stunden erzählen aber
nehmen wir nur mal das indische never
stop system also bei uns kennen wir ja
zwei steuersätze einen normalen und
ermäßigten satz für lebensmittel und so
weiter auch das ist manchmal schon
verwirrt aber für die bürokraten des
subkontinents ist das alles
amateurhaftes gependelt in den indien
muss nicht nur dieses produkt eine
eigene mehrheit steuer haben nein
manchmal haben sogar verschiedene
modelle desselben produkts
unterschiedliche mehrwertsteuersätze
ein weiteres beispiel sogar innerhalb
des landes zwischen dem indischen
bundesstaaten gibt es toll und macht
barrieren sowie in europa vor noch 200
jahren wenn du mal nach indien reist
werden die eventuell überall lange
schlangen von lastwägen mit waren
auffallen das liegt daran dass jeder von
ihnen eine interne zollkontrolle
durchlaufen muss und dass unter
umständen gleich mehrfach während einer
fahrt durch das land in zukunft der
außenhandel werden computer zwar
zollfrei sind belegt in denen alle
übrigen produkte von arzneimitteln bis
zur kleidung mit einigen der höchsten
zahl setzte der welt ja und die
rechtsextreme regierung von rameau die
macht die dinge nicht einfacher ganz im
gegenteil
wenn die im platz zusätzliche zölle und
handelsbarrieren für 300 importierte
produkte brothers so sind in den letzten
zwei jahre zum beispiel die us-firmen
anderson und volvo dies zielscheibe
geworden und genau wie gandhi im falle
von ibm früher möchte modi jetzt diesen
unternehmen das leben zur hölle machen
das geht sogar so weit dass ihre
vollkommene verbannung aus dem
e-commerce auf den indischen markt
diskutiert werden die confederation of
india traders will ein siebentägiges
verbot für amazon wegen verstoßes gegen
die herkunftsland regel bis zu decken
die frage lautet nun also warum den
ihnen die regeln für die
softwareindustrie nicht einfach auf die
übrige wirtschaft aus handelt es sich
bei ihr um eine blase die bei klassen
wird dann nämlich wenn die schere
zwischen teck india und michael ende
jahr zu weit ausgeht schreibt das alles
was ihr dazu einfällt immer in die
kommentare
denn wir sind auf diese schon hochgradig
gespannt ich hoffe dass wir dieses video
gefallen und ich etwas gebracht hat was
ja die uns mit einem daumen und
unterstütze uns im duett mit seinem
freund ist und vergesst nicht dass nicht
jede woche neue videos hochladen
abonnieren sie unseren kanal und klick
auf das klinikum rechtzeitig
benachrichtigt zu werden was gut und bis
zum nächsten mal